Поки що iPhone ще можна знайти в стамбульських магазинах електроніки.
Турки люблять ґаджети фірми Apple: вони - на другому місці за продажами.
Але президент Ердоган не поділяє захоплення американськими продуктами.
Він закликав турків бойкотувати їх і переходити на мобілки інших виробників,
приміром, з Азії.
Щоправда, турки, схоже, не поспішають реагувати на такі заклики.
- Для цього уряд спершу повинен заборонити імпорт та продаж
продукції Apple в нашій країні. Але як це можливо?
Ні, iPhone не можна так швидко вижити з Туреччини.
- Ми маємо вдома ще одну андроїдну мобілку.
Будемо користуватися нею. Я вважаю бойкот правильним.
- Я обираю продукт, який відповідає моїм потребам.
Мені не потрібно нічого вказувати.
Більшість населення не хоче купувати нові мобілки в тяжкі економічні часи,
які нині переживає країна.
Турки, може, й хотіли б підтримати бойкот,
до якого закликав президент Ердоган,
але проблема в тому, що нова мобілка коштує вчетверо більше,
ніж мінімальна місячна зарплатня в Туреччині.
Тож навіть найпалкіші прихильники турецького президента, вочевидь,
не готові витрачати так багато грошей заради боротьби проти Америки.
Є також дешеві мобілки турецького виробництва.
Акції виробника помітно зросли після заклику Ердогана.
- Ми підтримуємо курс нашої країни, тому тепер ми рекомендуємо ці мобілки.
У різних куточках Туреччини останніми днями
відбулися антиамериканські протести, як ось ця символічна акція
обміну долара на турецьку ліру - також після відповідного заклику Ердогана.
- Схоже, президент США не знає, з ким він зв'язався.
Йому протистоїть найбільш безстрашний чоловік, якого знає світ.
Його ім'я - Реджеп Таїп Ердоган.
Але якими б патріотами не виставляли себе турки,
більшість із них не хоче прощатися зі своїми айфонами.